ROBERT RAWSON: I do solemnly
swear--
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: I do
solemnly swear--
ROBERT RAWSON: That I
will faithfully,
impartially, and justly--
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: That
I will faithfully,
impartially, and justly--
ROBERT RAWSON: Perform the duties of
the office of President of
Princeton University--
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: Perform the
duties of the office of
President of Princeton
University--
ROBERT RAWSON: To the best
of my ability--
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: To the
best of my ability--
ROBERT RAWSON: So help me God.
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN:
So help me, God.
[APPLAUSE]
NANCY MALKIEL: I know the story
that she was a member of
the search committee, and one
day when she left to go to
teach, the other members of
the committee took the
opportunity to talk about what
was obviously on their minds,
which is that they should invite
her to step off the
committee and be considered
as a candidate herself.
VALERIE SMITH: Shirley brought a
real intellectual generosity
and openness to the position of
the presidency, and I think
we see that in the extraordinary
growth and
expansion of so many different
areas of the campus--
the arts, the study of
the environment,
African American studies.
The list goes on and on.
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: I've often
described the role of the
president of the university
as someone who is both the
greatest fan and the
greatest critic.
And I think in the case of
Princeton, one of the most
challenging things for a
president is to look at the
University without rose
covered glasses.
KATHRYN HALL: You know, there's so
many things that can happen
that are unexpected in
any new presidency.
And in fact, Shirley, even
before the official
installation, had to face, and
the university had to face,
the tragedy of 9/11.
But Shirley was able to approach
that tragedy in the
way she that she does everything
with warmth, with
understanding, with the
capacity to lead our
university through that very,
very, very difficult and
troubling time.
In fact, we're here today right
now talking in the 9/11
Memorial Garden where 13 alumni
who died on that day
are memorialized.
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: Today, we
gather as a community to
remember those who are missing
or who have been lost in the
tragic events in New York,
Washington, and Pennsylvania.
We grieve most especially for
those we knew personally--
family members, friends,
and colleagues.
NANCY MALKIEL: To have a faculty
member like that, so
admired and so well-known across
the campus, be selected
as president was simply
exhilarating, and to have it
be a woman for the first
time at Princeton was
just an added bonus.
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: Princeton is a
remarkable place, and it has
been so for many years.
But it is really important that
it not fall in love with
its propaganda, or its history,
or its reputation,
but be constantly critical of
what we are doing and how we
can do it so much better.
And that's really how I've tried
to think about my 12
years as president, to be able
to see Princeton clearly and
to see where the cracks
in the armor are.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: When
I think about Shirley
Tilghman's legacy, I think about
what she's added to the
social capital of
our university.
And some of that's been done
through the kinds of programs
that she's created in the arts
and other initiatives, but
some of it has been through
force of personality and her
leadership.
She has this stunning
combination of charm and
engagement and genuine passion
for the mission of Princeton
University, where she's led by
example by being out there on
the campus all the time, and I
think you can feel that in the
spirit of the place.
And when I walk around Princeton
and think about what
Shirley has done for this
university, that's what I
think about most.
JEFF NUNOKAWA: This, as I
understand it, is more or less
the beginning of what will be
Tilghman Walk, which will
traverse the world of the arts,
the infrastructure, the
architectural infrastructure of
the arts, over to the realm
of the sciences.
And that's, for starters, what
Shirley's all about.
I should say that's one of
Shirley's, one could argue, at
the heart of her accomplishment
as president.
One of the things I think
Shirley has done during her
tenure as president is draw
together all kinds of
constituencies, all kinds of
sensibilities, all kinds of
scholars, all kinds
of energies--
artistic, scientific energies
which had not been brought
together before.
This is what Shirley does.
It's what she knows how to do as
a person, and it's what she
knew how to do as a president.
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: I think from
really day one, the day I
walked into the office, I knew
that one of the things I was
going to promote is the growth
in neuroscience.
The surprise for me was what I
discovered in the course of
walking around, were the
limitations for students who
wanted to pursue the creative
and the performing arts.
Now, that was an area of the
university I really knew very
little about when I first
became president, but it
became pretty clear that we were
not serving our students
in the creative and the
performing arts to the extent
that they deserved.
And that began a long process
of beginning to understand
what our programs were, where
we needed to grow, where we
needed to become stronger.
And ultimately, thanks to Peter
Lewis, Princeton's great
benefactor, we were able to
create the Lewis Center for
the Arts and ultimately expand in
visual arts, theater, dance,
creative writing, and music
opportunities for students.
So that today when you walk
around this campus, you just
literally cannot avoid
being part of a great
community of art.
KATHRYN HALL: When the
financial crisis hit in the
fall of 2008, Princeton, like
every other institution, had
to really face some
important choices.
Shirley, with her leadership,
helped Princeton navigate
through that really
difficult time.
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: Those
headlines in the New York
Times just give you the smallest
idea of the impact of
the economic recession.
We have common cause, and that
is that all of us have been
affected by the equivalent of
an economic tsunami, the
perfect storm, where those
institutions with endowments
have seen a decline
in their value.
And all of us who are in the
business of raising resources
for our institutions know that
this is a very, very difficult
time to be asking people to give
to the things that they
care most about.
So this is indeed the
perfect storm.
[APPLAUSE]
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN:
Good evening.
[APPLAUSE]
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: Thank you.
Thank you.
Together, you've helped to
ensure that future generations
of Princetonians will continue
to receive the finest
education of its kind, and thus
equipped, will continue
to make our world a better
place for all.
[APPLAUSE]
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: Thank you.
Thank you.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: You
can see Shirley Tilghman's
legacy as you walk through the
Princeton campus with the new
buildings that have risen during
her time here and the
extraordinary programs that
reside within them.
And I think about everything
from the residential colleges
to the Neuroscience Institute,
the arts project that is
arising at the edge of our
campus and that will connect
Forbes to the rest of the
campus, the beautiful Lewis
Library, and Sherrerd Hall,
for example, up by
engineering.
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: Thinking about
engineering as a problem
solving part of the university
rather than individual
disciplines has been, I think,
a big part of the change and
the growth in the engineering
school over
the last few years.
Probably the most important
has been tackling the twin
issues of solving our energy
problems for the future and
protecting the environment.
So the Andlinger Center, which
was made possible, again, by a
great benefactor to the
university, Gary Andlinger, is
involving all of the departments
within the
engineering school, as well as
the Woodrow Wilson School and
departments in the
natural sciences.
The other area where we have
really focused a lot is in
thinking about the university
as one of the world's great
global universities.
It is a pleasure for me to be
here in Shanghai to engage in
this conversation that was
really inspired by William
Fung, who was a member of the
Class of 1970 at Princeton and
currently a trustee
of the university.
I think he described brilliantly
the rationale for
these conferences that we hope
to have in cities around the
world in the years to come.
It's really intended to
spark conversation.
Whether it's in Asia or in
Europe or in the United
States, Princeton is always
ranked as one of the world's
great universities, and if
that's going to continue to be
true, we have to behave like
a global university.
We have to think of ourself as
a global university, and that
means we have to be in the
world and of the world.
And so a lot of what we have
done by creating PIIRS
by creating the Bridge Year
program, by expanding study
abroad, summer global seminars,
on and on and on,
has been to make sure that our
faculty and our students are
going out into the world, and
that we are bringing the world
back to Princeton.
JEFF NUNOKAWA: I saw her at
a meeting of the faculty
recently where the faculty stood
up to acknowledge her.
And what I think was most
impressive to me was the range
of faculty there to approbate
her, the range of faculty to
approbate her from the heart.
This is a woman, a president,
a scholar, who values
scholarship of all
different kinds.
I just have difficulty imagining
how we could have
been luckier, as a university,
how we could have been luckier
than to have had Shirley at the
moment that we had her,
especially, I suppose.
KATHRYN HALL: It's a
superhuman job, and I think
that we have been very lucky
to have had Shirley in that
role, and we are extremely
fortunate to have Chris
Eisgruber coming up as
our 20th president.
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: Has this
been a challenging job?
Absolutely.
It's been a very challenging
job, but it's been a job that
has been immensely rewarding,
and I think that is what I
have focused in on rather than
focusing in on the challenges
as a negative, for example.
JEFF NUNOKAWA: There's just one
other thing I really want
to say, because it's
really important.
It's important to lot of us.
Shirley Tilghman is returning.
She's returning to our ranks.
She's returning to where her
heart has never left, and that
is the faculty of
this university.
VALERIE SMITH: I think as a
university, we are very
fortunate that Shirley will
return to full time teaching
after her leave.
Teaching is so close to her
heart and such an important
passion for her, and I think
we'll all benefit as a
community from being able to
have her wisdom in that role.
JEFF NUNOKAWA: Shirley's
coming home.
That's what I'd say.
She's not retiring.
She's coming home.
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: I've
loved this job.
I've loved it from the moment
I began to, I'm sure, when I
step off the stage on June 30.
It's been immensely rewarding.
It's great to see progress in
real time and to be able to
see the university get better
each and every day.
So I've just taken a lot
of pleasure from it.
[MUSIC]
Shirley M. Tilghman: Aim high, and be bold
My warmest wishes go with you all [APPLAUSE]